marcus we interviewed you in 2015
i believe holy crap really i know it's
been a little bit yeah
yeah that's a long time it's a long time
and it's fun though it was a great time
it was in ventura as a theater yeah
yes your interviews have uh
many many views many many comments
really some of them
positive some of them not so positive
and i have a question i was wondering if
you could address and that is
some of the people felt that you were
able to get a film made or sell a script
because you had previous connections and
can we
dispel that myth oh yeah totally i'm
completely locked in
because i was on a show a long time ago
so i know all the studio executives
and i know all the producers and i know
all the investors and they just give me
money all the time so it's super easy
and you just meet them you go to dan
tanto
hey marcus we're trying to make this
film would you like 30 million dollars
we're going to distribute it through
warner brothers and i'm like yeah great
sounds
awesome happens all the time for people
that don't live in la because la
i'm
but some people don't realize that like
they think that you
could be a bartender where hollywood
screenwriters or producers are and that
you can just get
someone's friend a script and that's not
really how it works here well here's the
thing like
yeah that's possible
like it's all possible you know i have
a friend who was a pa
and he was working on a studio a lot
and a very very very very very big movie
star
was shooting a movie on that line
everybody was super excited about it and
my friend the pa was like god i've
written this script
and this movie star is perfect for it
how do i find the movie star so they
couldn't find him like he was always
not around so they figured out
which car was his and the pa put his
script
on the movie star's windshield
and the movie star took the script
and my friend ended up being represented
by the movie star's agent
so yeah
all kinds of stuff can happen
um it doesn't mean that that's
going to happen it doesn't mean that
it's like you're set in stone
trust me i mean i'm flattered that folks
think that i was that big of a deal on
doogie hauser i was not
i was i was like the lowest guy on the
totem pole
i didn't have extra
connections i was working in an industry
i was doing my best to pay attention to
things
i had an agent that had no interest in
my scripts
uh i think i told the story the last
time
we talked i had a friend who was an
actor
he had a friend who was a manager
i did not know the manager i had written
the script
my friend was like you should meet my
friend the manager
that's how it happened it wasn't like
i mean i guess if if if the concern is
you had an advantage because you had a
friend yeah
i did um
would i had that friend if i lived in
kentucky probably not
you know what i mean but that doesn't
mean
that if you're in kentucky you can't
blow up in the film industry
because that happens a lot too like
people
enter contests or they submit their
scripts
to the sundance lab or whatever it is
and they're in wisconsin or they're in
idaho or they're wherever
and somebody sees that script they don't
have any connections
they just have a great script and people
go
we're gonna fly you out to sundance and
you're going to sit here and
we're going to help you develop then the
film gets made
and they blow up and they're sitting on
the dice and then they're making other
films and they're way past me
you know what i mean so you know yeah
everybody has advantages or
disadvantages
one way or another but you know i for
the record it's not like i was
connected in that sense
would you say too even if someone is on
this like trajectory of like
film after film after film even for that
level that it can still be like starting
from scratch
again for something that that person
wants to do if they want to do
a script the industry has a very short
attention span
[Music]
and a long memory
so if they remember you well
at a high enough level there's a lot of
stuff
you can try and you can do again um
i like to talk about people like danny
devito
kevin james everybody looks these guys
as leading men
and they are but they didn't start there
danny devito was doing off-broadway
plays playing a dog
like literally like on his hands and
knees barking
but he continued to grow and got to such
a point where people loved his work that
he became a leading man
same thing with kevin james not that he
was barking on stage but you know he was
a stand-up comedian
he was getting roles and stuff the
stand-up
career got him the show he was the
leading man in the show then he starts
being a leading man in in film so
you know you start where you are
and you grow from there but i think that
if kevin james had started off with his
first project
i was like i'm not doing this unless i'm
the leading man
i don't i don't necessarily think that
that would have flown
you know i think you build a repertoire
and people just
go with you if people like you they'll
follow you anywhere
look at will smith will smith was a
sitcom star
right but people loved the show and they
loved him and he was like i want to
become a serious actor and everybody
went
okay and they show up for his movies
you know it's like that's the thing like
it's not
advantages disadvantages everybody's got
them
everybody's got both but it doesn't mean
that what you want
is impossible you know
you hunker down and focus on it
none of these people are different from
anybody else
they're all humans they just
put their minds in a certain space
and we're like this is what i want i
deserve it
nothing's going to stop me that's all
really
anybody has to do and i know that sounds
you know dippy or whatever
but that's all anybody did
you know they got punched in the face
and they got punched in the face and
they got doors slammed on them
and they're like okay there's another
door
i'm gonna go over here now you know they
didn't necessarily get on twitter
and complained about the door they got
slammed on they just you know
just keep going that's all you can do in
my opinion
i could be wrong but that's what i think
markets regarding connections in
hollywood
i have a quote here i don't know who
said it
connections are good but nobody is going
to put their business in jeopardy
because of a connection that's
absolutely true did you say that
no okay i don't know where we got this
quote wait did i no i did
okay no i didn't
it's true though okay
it's it's a business
especially now and it's
become a very risk adverse business
especially now because
people don't like going to the movie
theater unless
spider-man's there
so studios
they're spending the money where the
money's going to get spent
so you can know
lorenzo david
benaventura who runs or one of the guys
that runs
warner brothers and you can be like hey
man
i know you're doing a lot of stuff right
now i got this musical about socks
lorenzo's probably gonna say you keep
that to yourself
you know what i mean it's a business and
and it's
shifting like daily especially now with
all the streaming wars going on
and everybody's pissed at netflix
they're
pulling their content off of netflix to
start their own streamers
and they're trying to brand themselves
like this is what we do
this is what we don't do and other
people are like counter
branding against that to get their own
it's a lot of money at stake
it's a lot of it's business like if what
you do
lines up with their business model cool
doesn't mean you're not talented doesn't
mean what you do
isn't great means it doesn't fit them
just had a pitch meeting that went
amazing
at a major
cabler and
executives were totally into what we had
done like this is really
funny and it's timely great
but they're rebranding and their brand
is this and
my show was this so they were like
it's great the writing's great it's
gonna be a fun show
it's not for us and that's
fine you know because everybody
is doing what they need to do for their
business
i don't advocate doing or changing
your stuff to fit somebody's business
but it doesn't hurt i don't think to
sort of pay attention to what
networks studios cablers
streamers what are they doing and what
do i have in my arsenal
where does it fit where does this make
sense
you know what i mean because you're in a
business too
your business is getting your brand out
there and
there's somewhere for every brand you've
got a brand
they've got a brand she's got a fun
brand
links up so
that's my very long-winded answer
to that question so when someone says
well
now i'm mad because person b
won't help me get to person a
and they're just trying to hold me down
and and it's just this industry is no
good everybody's trying
is that really it or is it just like
look we all have our own sort of name
and reputation at stake
i'd love to help you but
for that person yes that's true
because they've made a decision to see
it that way
so for them it's true it's absolutely
true um
the great thing about being a human
being
with a brain is you get to decide
how you see things you get to choose
how you react to what happens to you
so you can decide well this sucks
it's never gonna happen everybody sucks
when you take a script you put it in a
box put it under your bed
and walk around be mad or
you can say all right well those are two
people
in an industry with thousands of people
and somehow my work made me a friend
which means it probably will make me
another friend
so i guess what i need to do is keep
going
and find another spot another avenue
another outlet another way
to get this material that i believe in
into the right hands the right hands
is super important because it's not
about just getting the things
set up getting the things sold you can
get the thing set up and get things sold
and if it's in the wrong hands it's
gonna be crap
you know you need to be able to lock
in with whoever is going to be working
with you
to bring the thing to fruition that's
what makes
a film or a show great because everybody
for the most part gets on the same page
i mean there's always disagreements and
well i think this should happen i think
this character should be here not there
that's it's just part of it
but if the overall goal
is the same that's what you want so if
person b
cannot take you to person a or will not
take you to person a
it's not the right fit
there's a good fit it's out there it's
just not this person
and this person might be a better fit
for that other thing you got
so make sure you've got another thing
like
i tell the writers all the time like
if you want to get cooking and
you've got a script you dig that's
awesome
um you should never stop believing in it
but you should have something else
because again brands
people could be like i'm not into this
but i like the writing what else you got
and then if you don't have anything else
you're sitting there going uh
remember the attentions man it's really
short
so if you can't come back and say oh
yeah i got another thing
why don't we talk next week about the
new thing
people forget people see a lot of people
especially executives oh my god the
scripts that they read the pitches they
have to see
all the continual stuff
coming at them it's
very very rare for those guys to
remember
this one specific thing that i saw
three months ago they can
it happens if it really stood out to
that one person or whatever
but you know better your odds just keep
making content
you know it's important
i think last time we interviewed you in
you were in ventura right beautiful
ventura yes
and now you've returned to the la area
i know a lot of things have changed here
in terms of traffic and gentrification
all that
aside from those very real things have
you
noticed that the way the industry works
has changed
totally it's completely different
um in so many ways
like so all right 2015 so that's
four years um four and a half maybe
like everything's like the onset of
streaming is probably the
largest difference the onset of
the youtube influencers becoming
millionaires
on youtube huge difference
the changes we've had in
politics the changes that we've had in
culture um
yeah it's way different
now there are sections of people that
just can't get stuff done no more
you know because they're not the right
fit
for the way the world is
so yeah there's been a lot of
differences a lot of changes
when you've tried to get in front of
someone to pitch or whatever it is
get a project together do you notice
changes in that in terms of how it used
to be i don't know how long
you've been gone from l.a um
yeah i mean i am now in that
sort of midway point where
uh i'm interested in doing independent
things but
it's sort of evolved itself into a
higher level
so there's more money involved and
because there's more money involved
there's more
um necessities oh like what
um when you're asking folks for
more money they want some sort of
assurance
that they're going to get some return on
their investment
more often than not a great script is
not
that to them no matter how great they
believe it is
it's about eyeballs how can i get a
ton of eyeballs on this thing so that i
can turn a profit
get my money back or get my money back
and turn a profit
there's a lot of stuff going on right
now so
they need name attachments
director attachments something you know
it's why they keep making superhero
movies
that's why like everybody's like oh and
i know people love them and
and they should because there's a huge
worldwide
market for that but they keep making
them because
there's a huge worldwide market for that
you know so it's like hey i want to make
a movie about
flowers in the sun
i want to make a movie about iron man
we're gonna go iron man
because there's a lot more
there and you know some people love it
some people hate it but you gotta
respect it that's what that's
that's what that is you can't really
can't get around that so you've got to
be able to understand the business that
you're in
it's one thing to stick to your guns
creatively and i'm totally down for that
i completely respect that
because i think you have to be that way
especially in this business because it
can get very dogged
but you also have to respect the
industry and the way it works
a lot of people say it's not it's not a
place it's just your work
that gets it noticed so having moved
like two hours now back
do you feel that it's easier to get
stuff done now that you're here in la or
get stuff seen
rather than being just a short drive
away a beautiful train right away
yeah in a town that is gorgeous and you
can find a nice place to have lunch i
don't
know how you know there's like an
urgency to areas too
i've heard the same about san diego even
though it's again two hours from la
the urgency maybe isn't the same as when
you're in la
you need to move it you know i mean yeah
of course it's a it's a big city
you know ventura is not but that's not
the reason i mean the reason is who
you're working with and
and how much work you're putting in you
know i mean
if i was working with like
a really great production company right
and i was still in ventura at the time
it wouldn't i don't think there would
have been any sort of
time difference or or or difference in
getting stuff done it's just you know
just more driving
back and forth to meetings and stuff i
don't think it's i mean
yeah if you live in you know nebraska
it's better to be in la because there's
more stuff happening in
l.a than in omaha but you know
if you're just talking about you know an
hour or two drive difference
that's not any different it's just a
matter of like how much work you're
putting in
and maybe it's easier to be lazy
if you're not in town perhaps it's
easier
if you're in ventura or
like san diego or wherever perhaps it's
easier to not
put in the work because maybe it's
perceived as being harder
but it's not do you think there's an
energy here in la that pushes you to
keep working whereas maybe
ventura it's too comfortable it's too
like yeah i can find a parking spot at
the beach no problem
i know what i'm talking about i think
last time yeah and here when you will
drive around the block okay do i really
want to pay 20
to park in this lot right where i'm you
know i'm gonna have to park at the very
end
right no for sure i mean
listen if you live in a basketball town
and
you like croquette
it's gonna be very hard for you but if
you move to a town where they love
croquette you're probably gonna play a
lot more croquette
you know what i mean so yeah you're
you're in the city where it's happening
there's definitely
a bigger larger energy that's happening
in los angeles
everybody's not everybody but a lot of
folks are connected to the
entertainment industry people are moving
and shaking there's a lot of ideas
floating around
you probably can connect to people that
are part of your tribe easier because
they've already made the commitment and
they're here and they're doing stuff
i always admire people i meet people
that come here
and they're working and they're from
like sweden
you know what i mean and it's like so
you lived
like in sweden and you spoke swedish
but you wanted to make movies so you
left
everything you knew and you learned a
different language
and you got on a plane without any
guarantee of anything
and you took a one-way ticket trip to
los angeles and figured out how to like
get an apartment
and get a job so that you could pursue
this thing
like that's dude my head is off to
anybody who makes that trip that is i
just had to drive down from ventura
that's
nothing there are people coming here
from
countries you know what i mean like
they're leaving their families behind
they're like you know
suffering through holidays alone
lonely because they believe in something
like
there's no way you can not respect
that type of person
do you think it makes you more
competitive being here probably
are you competitive no yeah
can you still be successful and not be
competitive i hope so
i i don't know i mean no i mean
i think you got to do what you do and
then find folks to
dig what you do
you know you can get mad about something
or somebody is doing something similar
to you
and that's fine but then that's a lot of
energy
of yours that could be spent creating
something else of yours
spent on hating this person and you know
you know they don't give you time back
which is my understanding i don't know
i don't know if you get to the end and
then they go wow you save some time
so here here's another year and a half i
don't know that that happens
so you know i think i think it's better
to just be mindful of your own
your own track which again is why i'm
always saying
more than one thing always create always
always always always always always
especially like if you really dig
something like
if you've got a lot of stuff and you
really
want to do something a certain way if
you've got more content
you've got the option to save that
you know like i've got
i have a catalog of projects
and i have it split like this is the
stuff i want to do my way
and this is the stuff we're selling
and that
we really like this but we want to add a
raccoon to it do it
do it that raccoon could end up making
200 million dollars at the box office
and then i can pull this thing out
and i can say okay remember that movie i
made with you with the raccoon who made
all that money i want you to make this
movie now
and they'll go all right you gave us the
recall
so you know i think it's important to
have that it's not easy necessarily
i mean you know everybody's wired
differently
but i think the more stuff you can
stockpile
the better
what makes a good story depends on who
you're telling
you know some folks love
small town tales you know
i love netflix
always flipping around on netflix to
watch like all the stuff that no one
talks about
and uh i'm i'm a huge fan of asian
television
it's like a whole thing like singaporean
tv and
taiwanese tv like i'm like familiar with
the stars of that
area of the world now because i love
what they do
and it's really like super heavy
emotional
stuff so i don't know i watched two or
three shows with my wife
and she was like all right
i'm done it's way too emotional i'm
crying
i got my nose all stuffed up my eyes are
puffy
you find something to watch that's not
gonna give me a heart attack
so i found this show called
good witch and i thought it was gonna be
like you know a witch show i thought it
was gonna be like a supernatural
thing and we dig supernatural stuff
right so i'm like all right
that's cool this probably won't give you
a heart attack let's watch good witch
um she's not a witch like nothing
happens
like it's not it's but it's you know
it's made for a different audience
and i ended up watching the whole thing
of it and i was like all right
this is kind of cool it's not
what i would usually pick
but all right let me see what's cooking
here i don't think the people that watch
good witch
went to go see uh once pun time in
hollywood
you know what i mean and i doubt the
folks that went out to see once put in
in time in hollywood were like man that
was a good movie let's go home watch
good witch
like i don't think that you know so i
it depends it depends on um it depends
on who you're telling and
and it depends on who's telling the
story
you know i think you
you you tell a good story from a
relatable authentic place
and you tell it to somebody
who kind of understands that
that vibe that that feeling
so you know you can't say one
better than the other i know people like
doing that especially like
you know on on the interwebs i know
people like to
ah this is crap and this is terrible and
this is awful
it's like and that's all true to you
you know you watch something you think
it's absolute crap
it is absolute crap to you
but to somebody else i think it's great
it's kind of my problem with critics
you know because they're they're they're
they're you're you know it's
you're curating opinions and that's
fine but like
i don't know maybe it's me reading too
much into it but i
i just i don't personally think you can
say
well i decree that this is not worth
the time of millions of people because
it didn't appeal to me
critics hate adam sandler nobody's
stopping adam sandler from making stuff
you know what i mean netflix was like
here's
tons of money do whatever you want to do
and people show up does a great bon jovi
does do a great poncho he does i like
adam sandler i do too
it's really fun it makes me laugh well
you know and then there's different
things for different
moods that's true you know what i'm
saying yeah like you can be like
you know what it's a goofy night my
friends are out we're being stupid
let's watch a really cheesy stupid
horror movie let's watch attack of the
killer donuts and we'll get high
and laugh our asses off and it'll be
great
and then other times you want to watch
big little lies i was you know i was
just waiting for you to finish and i was
going to bring that up
yeah we must be having when he's done
i'm going to bring up big little lies
okay
i'm sorry go ahead no no it's all good
not right but wow that's weird
it's really like reading my mind see i'm
telling you
you're right you're right energy energy
because what i was going to say about it
sorry to cut you
no no was that i was resistant to the
show
i finally watched i was like wow this is
really good and i don't
normally want to go down that route of
like oh this is going to sound really
bad
but a bunch of women who have a really
good fight with each other
i kind of get tired of that trope yeah
because it's been
it's overdone and you know but i was
like okay wow oh she said oh my goodness
yeah she's going to do that
oh well look what she just did this like
power okay and then there was times i
was like you know what
i don't want to go there today right now
give me something else
it's not that it's not great writing
great acting love the set
love that it's set in monterey right but
some days i don't want to go to that
spot and but i was willing to go there i
was like
i can see what all the fuss is about you
get caught up yeah
i didn't think i was gonna like good
witch
and then i got caught up in the thing i
was like what what is cassie gonna do
now
i don't you know i don't know would i
ever
like write something like that probably
not
but everybody's got different stuff that
they want to do and
different moods that they're in and you
know it's funny like
i was watching uh comedians in cars with
coffee i think it's called the full
title
jerry seinfeld i can't remember who he
was talking to but he was like asking
his guests if they liked going to the
movies
and they were like yeah movies are cool
and then he's like
movies aren't any good it's not about
the movie
like you go there because you want to
get the popcorn and you get the seat
you get the candy you do the whole thing
who cares what the movie is you just
want to be in the thing you want to be
in the theater
you know maybe that's true it's
definitely true for him he said it
you know but i think i don't think
there's any
i don't think you can shame people for
liking what they like
right right you know if you if you like
award-winning cinema
that doesn't make you a better person
than the guy that likes
johnny knoxville movies you know just
that's what you like
like maybe maybe you've got to deal with
real intense serious stuff
at work and you don't want to have to
think about
all of the stuff that happens in
succession so you want to just like
laugh
i don't know you know that's why there's
something for everybody
all right remember rhonda shear up all
night oh my god
i mean sometimes those were great like
it was so cheesy
and and just like this ripped like
barbarian outfit or something but
there was it was like late at night and
sometimes you didn't want anything too
heavy it was like perfect
it's just fun you know i think i think
that's
i think it's good that we've got all i
mean it's like food
man i mean if you're
if you're a fit healthy person you're
eating the right foods
you're doing all the right stuff like at
a certain point you're
probably gonna want a slice of pizza
it doesn't make you like oh my god
hi i don't even know you anymore it's a
slice of pizza relax
you know i'll be hitting the kale
tomorrow it's
it's variety man it's it's every there's
something for everybody
at any point in time in their life or
mood or
whatever it's more about just enjoying
stuff i think
hey siri
yes what's the difference between plot
and story
are story and plot the same thing
i don't know i have no idea
it's a good question um
[Music]
should we should we ask siri i had
thought of that
the task let's try it let's do it i
don't know
okay hey siri
yes what's the difference between plot
and story
what's the difference between plot and
story
all right let's see oh great the
difference between
plot and story
did yours have more of like a british
accent yeah
oh i like the i like the british lady
she makes me feel that's cool classier
uh the king's english
a story is the requisite timeline of
events present
in any narrative no
story no novel because any novel
however abstract must report events of
some kind
a plot expresses rationale and informs
the reader
why a specific list of events belongs
together
what the timeline is ultimately meant to
communicate
so yes they are different you siri
it only took an eternity
so yeah do you think of that when you're
writing or no
none of that enters your mind it's not
you're not
not a single iota no
um i just try to think what's cool
what could be cool and then who could be
cool
and then what can they get into
and then how
uh that extrapolates into other stuff
i learned what is it called
i think it's called the law of
inevitability
and this was taught to me by david
greenwald
who i think got it from joss whedon
so basically what the law of
inevitability means is
if this happens inevitably this will
happen
and then if that happens inevitably that
will happen and then
if that happens inevitably that will
happen that's kind of the rule i
use i just kind of go
and then it becomes this really sort of
organic process because like i said
before i don't do all the stuff
and i'll do the outline and the thing
and the thing and the cards and the
don't do any of that
um i just sort of like to investigate
the characters
through the story and then all right
here's this scenario
okay so now that that happened what
would she do
well she would probably do this because
of that
but if she does that he's probably going
to do this
that's how i do it did you always feel
you had your own voice
no swearing no no
wasn't until i um
oddly enough left the city and
just started to not try to follow the
track
because you know there's like a track
there's like always like the hot
thing that's happening in town right
and so everybody's trying to come up
with their version of that thing
and then when i stopped trying to do
that i just started figuring out what i
liked
even movies and tv shows and stuff like
you know what do i like
um that's when like the voice
kicked in like that's when it's like
okay well
you've got a definitive opinion about
this
in society and so then that creeps in
how does someone know which story they
should write hmm
for me it's if i can't stop thinking
about it
you know it's like it's like it's like
dating you know
like if you can't stop thinking about
that girl you should call her
you know so if you've got this thing in
your head and you can't get rid of it
you can't shake it it won't go away
that's probably the thing you should be
writing
well you had an interesting story
without giving away too much information
about it because i don't want
anything to happen to the idea but which
is it was a more of um
it was an unusual story maybe less
unusual than we really think i don't
know
right but i found it interesting that
you found out that something that
writing from that perspective it was
from a woman's perspective oh yeah yeah
sort of her that's both facing shame
or perceived shame yeah yeah
that's kind of the that's that's kind of
my jam you like that
that sort of protagonist that's i do i
like
i like uh i like
i like uh i like horrible things
happening in beautiful places
that's my little lies yeah that's my jam
i like that stuff
um no i just i i uh
i don't know i write a lot from a lot of
a lot of female
lead characters uh i always have
it's just that now
it's cool before wasn't so cool
um i had a manager
and i wrote this thing and it was a
female lead
and he was like you should make this a
dude and i was like
i think dudes are good like i don't
think there's a shortage of
roles or dudes
so i'm gonna keep it a woman
and then we stopped working together
which was good because it wasn't you
know
it won the right fit you think as an
audience for harder
on female protagonists or women are
harder on them
both i think both
or we're just so jacked up man
our culture and society is so jacked up
about women
sexuality and did i tell you guys a
story
about the nipple no was there a wardrobe
malfunction
no no uh so i was working on this thing
um
[Music]
and it was you know it was like a big
sort of i guess
fantasy thing um
and it was like a crew of people
that had like these special abilities
and it was set in miami and they got
uh topless beaches down there
so me and my partner
we're working on the script and we have
the crew sitting on the beach
and the scene started with uh
the two women who were walking topless
down the beach
so the camera was going to pan from the
two topless women onto
the crew and then the crew and the scene
unfold
10 pages before this
the crew was in the swamplands of
florida
and they decapitated
and ripped the limbs off of
like five bodybuilders
then they like charbroid them charl
char broiled them there we go that's a
word
uh with fire
and fed the limbs to the alligators
in the swamp that happened ten pages ago
so the notes come back
we're trying to keep this a pg-13
[Music]
piece so let's
put tops on the women on the beach
who are ultimately going to be extras
you know
but we're gonna we need to put tops on
them
i'm like uh
not for nothing but did anybody read
what happened 10 pages before that scene
where like the dudes get ripped apart in
the thing
and they told me
you can decapitate 10
adult men and still be pg-13
one female nipple and it's rated r
has that changed i don't know
uh it was very eye-opening when i heard
it
when it happened um because
that sort of speaks to like i don't know
that's really weird that's super
weird it's like super weird we're so
much more comfortable with violence
than we are with any form of like
sexuality in this country well the woman
to the nipple she could be breastfeeding
really i mean we don't know in what
sense the nipple would be shown
well they were just walking down the
street they were walking down the beach
oh i see in that movie right
yeah they're just walking they were just
going to walk down the beach on the
topless beach which are
legal in certain areas of miami
and so this was a script you wrote
yeah i was i had a writing partner okay
that i was working with back in the day
and uh this was a piece that we were
working on and this was these were the
notes we got back
so so then did you put
bikini tops on the extras yeah
that's what that's what they wanted you
know so they have this they're paying
for
didn't have to change the scene 10 pages
prior like the dudes could still get
ripped up and set on fire and vent out
that's fine
that's okay but let's cover up those
nipples
you got to keep those female nipples
covered up because we're not trying to
make an r-rated movie
so i don't know
draw your own conclusions about what
that means
speechless i don't know i don't know
let's suppose you do get your script
some kind of traction on it where
someone answers an email
how how much not trouble but effort
is it to actually get a meeting and then
once you get a meeting what happens um
now it's it's not trouble but it
requires effort
um especially if you're playing in the
network studio game
because like everything is an upheaval
right now
um that's why i'm always saying like you
have to pay attention to the business
and what's happening and what people are
doing
and what's going on um
you can be dealing with a company
and you can deal with an executive in
that company
um for instance this is something that
we we dealt with uh had a piece of
material
had an executive that was interested
one set up a meeting and then
you know meetings don't happen right
away
because there's so many meetings there's
so many people
usually takes you know a week or two or
three to set the meeting up
so we set the meeting up
within that three week time frame that
executive no longer worked at that
company
they work somewhere else now so that
meeting
um at meetings in fantasyland
has nothing to do with anything like oh
well you know
i don't like you anymore people are
getting switched up like you know the
the networks and studios are
consolidating
you know disney bought fox
they're because they want disney plus
and everybody's doing a lot of stuff
right there's all kinds of shifting
around right now
and um we did a pitch went great
and then the executive branch
like the people running the studio that
owned the network
switched they hired a brand new ceo
hired all these new people those people
are now running everything
those people have a mandate that mandate
now has to come down the pike
our show which these executives dug
did not fit the new mandate so we're
done
again doesn't mean they didn't like it
but it's a business
like people are doing things very
specifically for
their brand for their companies i mean
that's
that's how it is now so you know again
like a broken record because it's like a
record oh nice
yeah what record is that i don't know
just a record it's
cool but like a broken record
have more stuff have more than one piece
have more content because things
shift up like crazy all the time
and especially if they like your writing
and the script that you wrote doesn't
fit the mandate that the company has
the executive can still say hey listen
if you've got anything else
that fits our bill please let us know
we'd love to hear it
so it behooves you to have
plenty of material let's say
your meeting is on the 25th the 24th
comes they're still employed there
you're still good to go
what are you doing the night before the
meeting and what are you doing
while you're in the ra and the waiting
room how early are you getting there
what's your strategy i you know i think
it's just you just prepare
you know i think i think if you've got a
pitch
you know the folks that i'm working with
great um amazing company
been doing it for a really long time
know the ins and outs
[Music]
we just would go over the pitch be like
okay
the meeting is three weeks out
so let's meet up every week and do the
pitch so we would sit down
would do the pitch what if he did this
what if we tweak that
move this round move that around all
right cool we'll come back next week
we'll do it again we did it again
you know what probably don't need to say
that let's do this just keep tweaking
and tweaking
getting super familiar with the material
you know and then go in and i
you know we just chilled they gave us
tea
and soda and we just
hung out and then they took us up to the
uh
this huge executive boardroom because we
had a we had a visual presentation
that went along with the pitch we
chilled out there
and they brought us more tea and soda
and
the executives came in we had this
killer pitch
and they were great it was fun and the
pitch was fun to do
like it's fun like you should be fun
you created this thing you love this
thing that should come across
like don't let the you know anxiety of
oh
i want to sell this thing you know this
would be so great like yeah
of course you want to sell it of course
it'll be so great but like don't
let that overwhelm
the joy of this thing that used your
baby you like created this thing that
you
totally love and then like this person
dug it and then they took it to this
person and that person dug it so there's
like this whole
like but by the time you pitch something
a lot of people like what you've done
so you're not nuts anymore you know what
i mean like
you write the thing and it's like well i
like it
i might be nuts and then like more
people like it
and now they want to get on board and
they want to help out and they want to
represent or whatever it is
so by the time you're sitting in front
of an executive there's a lot of people
that dig it
including the executive to a certain
extent because the executives already
heard the soft pitch of what the thing
is that you've created
and that was enough to make them say
come in here
so it's a big deal yes
but it's a big deal because you created
something people dig
so be happy about it we were thrilled
man it was fun
he was like yeah i've been working on
this thing for a year let me tell you
this part let me tell you that part
it was fun it should be fun i know that
sounds
you know too simple but
it's you're getting the opportunity
to share this really cool thing that you
created
with people who could potentially put it
out to the world
and the stuff you say are the stuff
they're going to say to their bosses
because they dig what you do they dig
what you say they're going to go their
bosses and say
same stuff you said that got them
excited
which will get their boss is excited and
then the next thing you know the thing's
on the air
and now they're getting millions of
people excited saying the same stuff you
said to them
in the room the first time so
you know just be excited about it it's
cool even if it doesn't
pan out it's cool you know you have a
good pitch people dig you
they'll let you pitch again that's a win
like getting in a room is a win it's a
big win oh so then always leave kind of
your
foot in the door in a graceful way so
you can come back i think
yeah i think you do that by just being
cool
i think if you write something good
because the whole point of the pitches
is to get them to read the thing
right because nobody wants to read
anything right it's like oh i gotta read
nobody wants to do that so you pitch
them the thing to get them excited about
the thing
so they go all right all right let me
read the thing
this is cool that's funny that's weird
all right whatever
so you get them excited about reading
the thing they like the way you handle
yourself
and they like how you write it presents
itself
the open door presents itself like the
pitches that we've done
what i've done with the company we've
just
gone in with the attitude of like let's
just have a great time
we know what we want we know the show
you know what we came here to do let's
just go in there and have fun
if we have fun they'll have fun and
so far we've been welcomed back
when you're practicing and you're in
front of someone else
like what are the how does this practice
session go
it's kind of like for me it's like uh
it's very
challenging for me because the easiest
part of the process for me is writing
the script
that's the easiest part like everybody
like agonizes over that i'm just like
when can i just sit down and write the
script
i don't i don't talk about all the other
stuff and the thing is
it's so much more challenging for me to
sell
a project than it is to just write the
script
it's like what's it about here's 42
pages i'll tell you everything you need
to know
it's all in there i wrote all of it it's
easy
but that's not how it works so you got
to get in there and you got to dissect
it
you got to like analyze it and you got
to figure out what it means
to the world and how it's timely right
now and what are the themes and what are
you trying to say
about the world that we live in so we
basically wrote a script
about that so it's like a script about
the
script and i say this part you say that
part i say this part you say that
part i say this part you say that part
well you know what
this is the actual plot of the pilot so
since you wrote it
you should say that part well this part
is about the female character that
is kind of controversial you're a female
you should say that part instead of me
so you toy around with it and then you
present and then you memorize it like
you do
a performance that's we did anyway other
people might do different stuff but
that's that's how we did it
but yeah i'd rather just write the
script itself
when you leave the pitch do you have a
good intuition about how it went or
is it like they could just love it and
you have no idea and then they're not
gonna
get going with it and then the opposite
not i you know it's we went through that
i mean we had the pitch and then we left
and we felt good about
doing it and we felt good about the way
they responded but they're executives
like their job is to sort of like not
give you anything
like that's you know like all executives
are probably really good at poker
because like that's their job they can't
you know they're not gonna they're not
gonna
like open up a checkbook in the room be
like this is great how much you want
like
they're not gonna do that there's like
all kinds of checks and balances that
have to go on
so they can't really give you much of
anything except for
you know
undivided attention so the pitch we had
the executives came in and it was
undivided attention
like nobody was checking the phone
nobody was doing this
nobody had like other stuff they were
flipping through
like it was us the presentation in them
and they were in it and we were in it
and that felt great
but you know the pitch ends and they go
this sounds great
send us the script we'll be in touch
so you leave so the good thing about
that is
send us the script if you get people to
the point where they want to read
something you've done something right
because nobody wants to read anything
nobody wants to read you know what i
mean so
that's the good thing that you pick up
on but you you drive yourself nuts
trying to figure out
well you know did they think what they
think they said this word
is that you think that's good do you
drive yourself nuts
you know you gotta just kind of gotta
rely on yourself and how good you feel
about
what you're doing what you did and then
let the rest of it
fall and broken record best thing for
that
have more material because if you've got
other stuff
then you got one pitch with one project
but that's cool if that doesn't fly i
got all this other cool stuff
so again all this sorry internet
have more stuff you said rely on
yourself were you always
that self-reliant i
no probably not i was more angry
you know first script i ever wrote i
wrote because i was angry
at tv
[Laughter]
i remember watching something i don't
even remember what it was but i was like
seriously this is supposed to be comedy
this is crap
better than this that's how i wrote my
first crap
so my first trip was written out of
anger um
it was always just like oh i think about
that and then that evolved to
sort of appreciating the process of what
happens
you know what i mean it's weird like if
you're working on a show
well at least when i was working on a
show it's like a kid
straight out of high school and pay a
whole lot of attention
to the process you know i had my job
which was to play the role that i had
been hired to play
say these lines appropriately
and then you know go hang out with my
friends
i didn't know the process of like the
writers having to sit with the
show runners and the director and let's
change this
and the executives want this to be in
the episode and you can't do that and
we've got all
and pay attention to any of that but you
know you
you learn as you go
and then the first time you write
something the actual effort
to actually write something in itself is
it's super easy to be like that's stupid
like that's super easy but like nobody
nobody sets out to like make something
stupid
like nobody's like all right you know
what here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna make a shitty movie like
that's our goal
nobody does that you know there's a
process that
you go through and the process from your
brain
to the screen there's all kinds of stuff
in between that
you know what i mean so
so no i just i think i just i think i
just learned
and i got more comfortable with
what i wanted to say and i got more
comfortable with
the way i said it i got more comfortable
with my own process
of how i wrote you know i tried all the
stuff
and it just wasn't comfortable and i
could i never finished anything
but if i just kind of
let myself get lost in the story i ended
up with a story
and i just decided well this is what
works for me
if it sucks it sucks but i'm having fun
i like it having been a teenager
and being in the industry still being in
it now
do you think you've been able to
separate the rejection
um from the work versus they're
rejecting you
oh yeah yeah i mean
i think everybody should live a year of
their life
as an actor like everybody
just so that you can understand
how meaningless no is
you know what i mean like anybody can
say no to anything
okay great there's like
billions of other people there's all
kinds of other stuff going on
like everything you've seen somebody
said no to it
probably several people said no to it
before you saw it there's a thing that
was on twitter
um uh which i
got off of which i'm so happy about
anyway
there was this thing on the twitter and
it was like
share your stories of rejection
or something yep and you got all of
these
writers and actors and everybody was
just like you know i remember one guy
was like i
sent my script to this
festival and they told me it was unfunny
and unstructured there was no focus
and there was nothing anybody could do
with it it premieres tonight
starring jim carrey on showtime i saw
that tweet right
i saw them say yeah it's awesome but
like if the dude had gotten all of that
nonsense and been like oh well i suck
and ripped up the script we're done
you know what i mean who cares that that
person said no
i think i read it to you yeah i think i
read that that's so funny it's like
you're gonna hear no and then you're
gonna
get back up and then you're gonna do
something else
and maybe in the know you hear something
that teaches you something
or it doesn't who cares whatever
you keep going so and i think
acting is like that's all you do as an
actors get told no
no no no not you oh no no
no no no thank you now no
and then all those people become stars
so yeah i think everybody should be an
actor for a year of their life just so
that they can
understand that rejection
is kind of pointless
speaking of acting fight club yeah so i
was watching a joe rogan interview
and he was talking about a huge part of
martial arts
is one's relationship with the master
the coach right and um
joe says that it's like the one who can
guide you through the most dangerous
waters
and so he was interviewing none other
than fight club's
writer is it chuck pollinick hard to say
the last name
okay all right good good all right um
which in the film you play the detective
kevin
okay in the movie so does a writer have
a coach
or is that the audience i'm not talking
about a writing coach that you hire
but like sort of a sensei you can yeah
of course
or or is it the audience eventually that
becomes that
mr miyagi who's kind of like well this
is what it was
it can i mean if you if you allow
the audience to define the work
then yes i mean
yeah a mentor is always great somebody
who can like look at your script
objectively
you know i've done it for people i tell
people all the time
you don't want different you just want
better because there's a difference you
know
if someone is reading your script and
they're coming at you
and all this stuff that changes it
around
that's not necessarily good you know
but if they read your script and they
see
what you're doing and they say all right
i get this here's a better way of
bringing that out
that's what you want that's what a coach
would do that's what a
writing mentor would do sort of help you
bring out
your story to the best of your ability
once you hit that get at that point you
know an audience can see it
and analyze it and say oh we like this
or we don't like that
and they have that right but
the story's done you know
it's not like you make a movie
or a story comes out or whatever
you know an author doesn't write a book
and then the audience is like well this
sucked and you should have done that and
this should have happened
then the author goes back and rewrites
the book and re-releases the book
you know it's already out it's done so
yeah there's stuff you can
take from that say well people kind of
dug that kind of didn't dig this
so when i make my next move i can
i can keep that in mind but yeah it
never hurts to
have somebody that you can bounce off
ideas and
and scripts and scenes with as long as
they
are in alignment with what you're doing
you know what i mean if you write
if you write reservoir dogs
you don't want your mentor to be crazy
rich asians
you know what i mean because you're
trying to shoot people
and kill them and raw banks and whatnot
and they're like where's the romance
it's different different so people do
have to understand what you're doing and
where you're coming from
that's important and on the same show i
think either joe or chuck said something
about how a bad
coach or master can really damage
someone yep
so is that almost the critic
i don't think a critic is a coach
because again critic
shows up at the end
you know that's true it's like the
audience the audience and the critic
they're kind of in the same
boat because they're sitting there
watching the end result
of all the stuff that's already been
done you know you need somebody that's
there
at the beginning when you're hatching
the idea and they go
that's cool that's cool what if you came
at it from this angle
same deal but like maybe this opens it
up
more people and you go oh yeah that's
cool that's good that's good
that broadens the scope or it broadens
the audience or broadens like you know
the viability of it that's what you want
credit can't do that credit can only
show up
at the end and you know take [ __ ] all
over
what someone's already done you know
what i mean
what's the character in um leave it to
beaver
the uh the one that said always misses
nice to mrs cleaver
but then oh my god sorry
the oh gosh i'm beaver
so so he's the blonde guy and he's oh hi
mrs cleaver
oh lovely dress you're wearing today and
then to
to to the beaver he's like throwing spit
balls on him
so that's the critic
i think i mean i you know i don't know
all of them
i don't know them all i mean some of
them could be great
and cool and you know really
in too and care about stuff but i don't
know
in my opinion it's easier to destroy
than it is to create
wow that's really interesting so i i
you know i know that's really
interesting
there's a there's a really really
great filmmaker who said that
uh any review
good or bad means nothing
so there's no point in reading them
even if they're good there's really no
point reading them
because it's just one person's opinion
so
make your stuff get it out to people
find your audience you know i mean can
you imagine
if like adam sandler cared about critics
be done and there might be people be
very happy about that
because they'd be like ugh thank god
good riddance he sucks
but then there's other people that would
be like are you kidding
adam sandler got me through whatever
right
it's all art i don't i don't personally
understand how you can
uh
i don't know critique
art you can
talk about it you can have
your own personal feeling about it
but it's all subjective
you know what's that one man's
trash is another man's treasure you know
i mean
okay that's fine you can have a thing
but
i know there's a lot of stuff that
critics
love like on a unilateral level
and then i see it i don't like it
and then there's like stuff critics hate
and
i see it i kind of like it you know what
i mean
like so they're not necessarily talking
from where i'm at
you know what i mean so i i mean i know
the industry
there's a big thing and they want to
have that critical acclaim and
i understand the benefit it brings a
project
and it's all great but
you know it's like oscars right it's
just again
it was just i was just thinking that
what's the thing
the another filmmaker is the whole idea
behind the oscars as
it's assumed um that that the oscar that
wins best picture or whatever is like
the best movie
and it's not necessarily the best movie
you know it's the movie that had the
best campaign
and had like the most amount of friends
that were in the academy
to get it the most votes not that it's
not a great
it could have been might might be the
best movie who knows
but that's not the only deciding factor
as to who gets an oscar
right you know he had people for years
going when the hell is leonardo dicaprio
going to get an oscar he's like putting
in all these
great performances right and then he
finally got one
and everybody's like it's about time but
like you know
maybe he should have had four i don't
know you know what i mean like it's all
it's it's
it is what it is and it's it's what you
dig
if you dig it who cares
what anybody else thinks
why is screenwriting hard it's not
it's not okay next question should we
ask
siri i don't know okay no i i don't
think it's hard
um
anything's hard that you know
you're forcing
[Music]
anything's hard you're forcing if you're
fortunate
it's hard it then maybe is the career
aspect of it hard so maybe it's easy the
screenwriting process is easy
oh yeah the the navigating of a career
is always more challenging than
doing the actual thing you know
like there are tons of incredibly
talented actors
that are not stars for one reason or
another
that has nothing to do with how talented
they are
as actors same thing with writers
directors musicians songwriters
you know a career trajectory is a
completely different
skill set you know i mean that's why
it's so important to to either have
someone
who can guide you through it or figure
out
how to market stuff
so that it appeals to the people you're
trying to get it
to but yeah like you know i said earlier
way easier to write the script than
pitch it
that's i they'll ask you for like a log
line
that's like a few words it takes me
forever to figure out
but you want 100 pages of a script
done easy gotcha now you want me to take
those hundred pages and put them in a
sentence
why i got 100 pages you know
so it's just different skill sets but i
don't necessarily
i don't think it's i don't think it's
necessarily hard
you know it can be challenging can be
difficult there could be research
involved it's you know
not necessarily easy but i wouldn't
categorize it as
hard unless you're forcing it or there
are forces
impeding on the creative flow
necessary
so were there times where you had
someone that wanted to quote guide your
career
and sometimes it's better to go on alone
like
yeah to someone that saw
things in you and they thought this
would be great let's work together on
the
trajectory of your career and maybe
early on you could
kind of see maybe that would be better
just to be on your own
yeah it's like the manager told me i
should
change the script make it a dude when it
was written about a woman
it's like he's not wrong
not right he's not wrong it's just a
different
it's a difference you know people get
caught up in like
right wrong blame this that it's like
there's stuff that is
and then there's stuff that isn't like
whatever perception you put on it
is your perception you know
you get way more i get way more
accomplished
with that mindset than trying to figure
out
right and wrong and this and that and
i like this i think this
works i think this proceeds in a manner
that would be entertaining
to millions of people what do you think
i think it should be like this this this
this this
okay what do you think
i kind of dig it i think you can make
some tweaks make it even cooler what are
your tweaks
those sound really cool okay we should
work yep
that's all i think it comes down to you
know it's it's
it's if it's not a fit it's not a fit
it's like anything else it's like
friends
it's like dating it's like a marriage
it's
if you're constantly doing this
maybe it's not a fit maybe
it's not a fit maybe there's a better
way of
getting your work seen heard
done you know tyler perry was
homeless trying to figure it out
couldn't get anything cooking started
turning the scripts into plays
now he's sitting on top of an empire
he's worth hundreds of millions of
dollars
doing whatever he wants to do
i'm sure somebody told him well this is
dumb
tyler perry you shouldn't do that
maybe they were right maybe it would
happen quicker maybe they were wrong it
happened the way it was supposed to
you know what i mean so
i just think it's a i just think it's a
matter of perspective
i just think the most important thing is
for you as a writer to know
who you are as a writer like you have to
know
who you are what you do because
they don't you know what i mean like
they may have ideas about what they
think it could be
and if that links up with what you are
awesome
but you gotta know
like you got to know where you want to
go what you want to do how you want to
do it
the kind of thing you dig the kind of
thing you don't what you're good at what
you're not good at
because otherwise you get stuck in this
battle
and you got an agent or a manager or
executive or producer trying to get you
to do something that's not what you want
to do and
it's no good so not just the writer's
voice
but what they want to do with their
career what kind of projects they know
they're going to get
i i think yeah i think a writer should
understand their identity as a writer
does it mean you can't branch out and do
other things
you know what i mean it doesn't mean you
can't branch out and like attack
different genres and stuff
but i think you know you should
have a very clear understanding of who
you are
as a writer just like you should have a
very clear understanding of who you are
as a person
you know like you know people are
different
and they have different attributes and
they have different
value systems and that's who they are
yeah
you know for better or for worse that's
who they are but they know who they are
when they know who they are i think a
writer it's the same way
this is what i do you know what i mean
you watch a shonda rhyme show you know
what you're getting
and now even things that she doesn't
create but things that she executive
produce
still feel like the things she wrote
because she knows what she does as a
right this is what i do
this is this is it ryan murphy
who runs the gamut from american horror
story to glee
but there's still a thread in there that
lets you know that's ryan murphy
that's what he does the late stephen
bochko
that's what he did you know what i mean
like there's there's a there's a
identity there's a through line that
comes from this is what i do
steven j cannell yeah all the great
show runners that people know you know
maybe they don't know the title
showrunner but
you know these impresarios
and in film too martin scorsese
who ran the gamut from you know
goodfellas to
the age of innocence still a martin
scorsese movie
you know
he knows he knows who he is i think a
writer should too
i passionately hate the idea of being
with it i think an artist always has to
be
out of step with his time and
if that's right from the internet it's
orson welles
which i can totally picture him saying
yeah and i think
i think there's value to that
i also think it's a statement from a man
who lived in a very specific era
it's different now than it was
orson welles was a total innovator
and he worked in an industry that works
very different from the way it works now
and it was a much smaller industry than
it was
but again i think the core
of that quote speaks to identity
right because he says i i disagree with
being with it
right you should be out of step with
what's going on or out of step with your
time
which i interpret like it's more
important
to know who you are as an artist than it
is to be trying to copy
what's happening in the marketplace you
know what i mean that's my takeaway
from that um so yeah i think there's
definitely value to that but
i think there's a little wiggle room in
there
well not only was he not really with it
but
when the hearst saw citizen kane
they weren't happy with it and he was
actively
uh they tried to stop him in many many
ways
a lot of trouble a lot of trouble for a
lot of years a lot of trouble for not
being with it
but again it comes down to is the juice
worth a squeeze which is what i love
i love that saying i can't remember
where i got it from it's a ventura
saying
it's orange i don't know i'm just
kidding with the orange juice
juice so no it's like is the juice worth
the squeeze
so like all right is it worth the effort
to do this thing
whether that be what you perceive the
outcome to be
or whether it be your own personal
passion
like whatever it is it's like if it's
not worth this
don't do it but if it is absolutely do
it
you know you can uh
there's a lot of people that are
considered ahead of their time
that are wonderful artists that are
revered
and respected but die broke
right who's the i don't know
van gogh or whoever everybody
loves the stuff now dude dad bro might
have the wrong one
sorry internet i might have the wrong
one i'm not sure but
i think most people would like to
be appreciated and profit from what they
do
while they're still here you know what i
mean you know what i mean
yeah yeah that's not to say you can't
be authentic to who you are as an artist
you know what i mean i think that's
absolutely necessary
because that's what gives you a voice
and it's your unique voice
that i believe people will respond to
because they see
their own thoughts and feelings in what
you are presenting
but uh
yeah we were just talking about the last
black man in san francisco
great film which i still have not seen
oh you haven't oh okay then i don't know
i like
i just i'm sorry okay and i want to
bring it up i i
like to follow the stuff i like to be
aware of things but there's a lot
there's been a lot of writing
going on so there's a lot of stuff i
haven't seen okay
a lot the last movie i saw in theaters
i think the last one i saw it was
definitely last year i don't want to
ruffle anybody's feathers no no
it was last year okay so i've been i've
been near you know we've been working on
a lot of stuff so i haven't seen a lot
of stuff and i try not to go to movies a
lot
why um if i'm actively writing
i try not to watch
stuff that much
because i don't want to have something
download into my brain
that it's not me it's not mine
but i've been watching something else
and i thought it was cool and then it
comes out and my stuff
i'm like oh this is cool and really i'm
just copycatting something that i heard
or parroting
something that i saw so when i'm
working especially the way i'm working
now
i try to i try to not watch
a lot of stuff try to stay away from
this the zeitgeist
i say that right i guys yeah i think so
try to stay away from it so i don't
i don't copycat it so i haven't
but i do like to keep up with the titles
i like to watch
um the numbers
it's nice to see what's doing what what
the marketplace how it's
moving um especially in the independent
market
like what's selling what isn't what's
doing well
what people are responding to i think
that's still an important
aspect of any career i think you i think
you got to watch it
you know i like to i get the hollywood
reporter newsletter
in my email every morning so i go
through it and
pay attention to stuff there might be a
company in there we're trying to get to
they might be a little blurred about
what's going on with them i confer with
my company and
start talking oh well you know just
heard this
what about that take that to them sounds
great let's try that aspect
so i think it's good to know what's
going on
but no i haven't i haven't seen the last
black man in san francisco but i hear
it's
a wonderful film should a screenwriter
have different piles
for completed screenplays yes absolutely
like you should know like
your stuff that's good for the
marketplace and you should know stuff
that
you want if that's the career you want
right like some writers just want to be
writers that's that's all they want to
do
they just want to sell sell and that's
totally fine other writers
have pieces that they want to wait on
because they want
bigger budgets for them so they want to
build up you know their
rep reputation or whatever
other writers want to direct things
so that they can you know control the
vision of it
and so they should hold on to those
pieces
while they're building up their
repertoire selling other things
john sales did that
john sales would write huge big budget
films for the studios they pay him a ton
of money
and he takes some of that money he makes
his little movies
as a director you know so
oh my god why does his name escape me
damien chazelle
same thing like if you look through his
imdb you'll see like all these films
that he wrote
and some of them were like horror films
like the dude that made lala land
wrote horror movies you know what i'm
saying
so it's like yeah okay yeah i got that
let me do that
sure give me the money that's fantastic
and then
over here is what you got
he and
what is his name i can't believe i can't
remember his name he's such a great
director
what what's uh one of those he directed
black panther
oh ryan cooper or no no brian coogler oh
okay
ryan coogler uh
grew up watching rocky
loved it had a whole take
on how to bring it into the 21st century
he had done fruitvale station i think
and
he signed with his agency i believe it
was william morris i don't know i'm not
sure but
they're like what do you want to do and
he's like i want to do
creep they're like nah
sylvester stallone's done don't he's
done with it don't do it
do something else so he did something
else and then that made money and
they're like this is so great
we made all this money what do you want
to do
free but now he made all the money
so they put him in front of sylvester
stallone and he got to pitch it to
sylvester stallone
who was done with the character but ryan
had so much passion for the story and
the character and what
sylvester stallone created he's like all
right
let's do it do it your way
and that's how we get creed so we got la
la land
damien had done a bunch of stuff he got
a lot of attention in the industry
if you're like what do you want to do
lava land they're like oh
musical no no nobody's gonna see a
musical
so he went he made whiplash yes
loved it big hit oscar winner oh my god
you won an oscar
that's great what do you want to do la
la land
all right all right we'll do it now they
gave him 30 million dollars
for the movie that wasn't supposed to do
anything and became a phenomenon
so you know you got to have
an idea of what you want to do what
you're passionate about what you're
willing to fight for
and stuff that you you know proud of and
let them do what they're going to do
with it
but again you can't have piles unless
broken record you got more content so
keep creating content
i like the john sales reference i really
loved passionfish
you see that one was that considered one
of
his projects okay i believe so
i mean he had such a long career at that
point
you know what i mean so i think at a
certain point
you start to
if if you do it right i think the
careers start to mesh
where you know you make enough films
that you know do well
on that studio level you make enough
films
uh independently that do well
and then i think at a certain point you
start they start merging
they start coming together you know what
i mean and it's like
this is just what you do now you know
it's kind of uh
kind of what happened in woody allen's
career you know he was
doing this and then this happened and
then that happened and then after a
while he was just
it was just you know the studio would
give him the money
do the movie which is interesting
because
i have a woody allen quote right here oh
my god so
and it says if you're not failing every
now and again it's a sign you're not
doing
anything very innovative yeah
yeah i think so i agree with that
you could say someone like m night
shyamalan great made some
excellent films and unfortunately when
people didn't like for whatever reason
his other movies
how it was almost like they forgot about
the other work that he had done
yeah that was so amazing luckily he's
coming out with more things now but
short attention span long memory yeah
yeah the only
cure for that is material
you know what i mean it's like you just
spike lee
you know black klansmen hits all of a
sudden
boom oscar right
profitable everybody's talking about
spike lee again
but you know he built that up and built
up enough of
material fans within the industry
you know jordan peele's like all right
let's do this thing
which makes studios a little more
comfortable
you know i mean so you you do have to be
aware of
how it works steven soderbergh as well
kind of like i think he's always said
like one for him and one for
the quote unquote system bruce willis
used to have the same
he used to have the same that's how he
got uh oh man what was the movie
no it was it was sixth sense tell you
that
interesting he wanted to do six cents
and they were like we want you to do the
kid
and he's like all right
if i do the kid you let me do the sixth
sense disney like all right
but you gotta do the kid so he did the
kid terrible movie
but you know how competitive
is being a screenwriter is it more or
less competitive than
trying to be an actor
i think it's just different like a
different kind of competition
you know um
you're just dealing with a different
medium really
it's probably the same amount of folks
you know
because internet
you know folks are sending in tapes from
all over the country for things
people can send in scripts from all over
the country for things
you know and then you have different
tiers of things you've got like your
stars
that are auditioning for bigger projects
and then you feel your way down and then
you have your a-list writers
that are competing with original scripts
plus they're also competing for
you know writing assignments and you
know show runners or
pitching shows to networks trying to get
their shows on the air
and you've got the writers below that
are trying to get staffed
based on the scripts that they're
writing so you know it's just a
different medium but
i don't i don't i don't necessarily know
if one's
more or less competitive
really would you ever want to be in the
tv
writers room like if you knew for one
year you could do something
and it'd be long hours and you'd have to
really just give up your entire
social life yeah everything would you
want to do it
you know i mean i'm out there right now
pitching television shows
so you know
it's it's the nature of the beast
i mean i'm not so uh
not so egotistical to believe that
anyone will allow me to run a show
even if i create it you know what i mean
um
and i think there's a lot of value of
being in a writer's room for sure
so i mean is it my first choice of
something
nah but
i think it's probably an inevitability
if i keep creating television shows
you know i might even buy some
they'll have to be in there write an
episode
unless i write all the episodes myself
which would be cool
because it'd be like a big long movie
that'd be cool
i'd like to do that is it easier for you
to now
you know take meetings and things just
because you're closer
you mean proximity-wise yeah no
it's not the proximity it's the people
you're working with
you know it's the folks that the people
i'm working with now
they're just that they're at a higher
level
in the industry they have relationships
across the board studios networks
they know who the executives are and if
they don't
they are friends with other executives
that know who the right executives are
so it's a matter of sort of curating
my catalog of scripts and looking at
where the relationships are
and setting things up
and getting in rooms or sending scripts
or finding other ways
through other mediums different other
companies or or or music production
companies or music supervision companies
or or
talent casting to get
the material in front of people
who can either make a decision
or have the ear of the people making the
decision
so i mean i could have met these folks
when i was in ventura and it would have
been the same thing
in fact i did meet him while i was in
ventura
i just happened to move to venice
because i love venice i always wanted to
move back there so
but yeah it's not it's not a proximity
thing again like i said before you know
if you're in montana
it's probably harder but it's just an
hour away
do you like to write in the the busy
coffee shops or whatever in venice no i
mean there's a lot going on in venice
it's very busy it's a lot going on
venice is so cool i love it um but no
i've never been a coffee shop
writer person i don't know
it just seems odd for me i know a lot of
people work in coffee shops and it's
like cool to like network and
i know a lot of like writing partners
will get together in coffee shops and
write
um i don't know i don't want all that
stimuli
you know i just i want to be in here
you know plus i don't drink coffee so oh
that's the other thing oh that would be
yeah
i don't really drink coffee and they
don't they don't have the equivalent of
of uh you know for whiskey
if they had the equivalent for whiskey
that i might do
okay if they were like you know the
starbucks
of whiskey i might go into that
and do because i like i like to like to
have a glass of whiskey
sometimes a little cigar oh nice and
then like
please relax me nice
it's nice that's how i like to do it
not a whole lot of other stuff around
i like to just dive deep in here and
make stuff
up just like when i was a kid and then
write it down
and then finish once my brain is like
fried
and then you know relax
once you finish your first draft what's
your process with it
mine personally
everybody's gonna hate this
uh i send it to the company i'm working
with
first draft really yeah
i send it to them and they look at it
and we talk about it they give me notes
and because we work so well together
it's like a real symbiotic relationship
they understand
not just like
the kind of material that i do they
understand
where i want to go like they understand
where i want to be in 10 years and 20
years and 30 years because we've had
these conversations
and we've worked on so many projects
together
in fact i'm working exclusively with
this company now
and they just i mean when i go into the
office
we're usually in there for like four or
five hours just because we vibe
we're having fun we're telling stories
we're getting work done but it's just
this
really cool i'm so grateful to have
found these people they're amazing
so yeah i trust them so i finish a draft
and i send it to them and they read it
and they're honest with me and we go
back and forth and we get it figured out
and uh yeah
yeah it's good but i will say this i
don't uh
i don't write out of the gate
right so it's not like oh here's a cool
idea
yeah and i start writing it
i don't do all the other stuff i don't
do that outline and all that mess
but um i will sit on it
i think it's something i think is cool
and i'll sit on it
and i'll just start imagining it
like i'm watching it in my head
and i see
abstract scenes i don't see it
like front to back but i'll see a scene
with these characters i'll see another
scene in another
area and when i get enough of those
pieces
then i start thinking about okay how
would this start
like how would it open and then
once that comes to me then i start
writing it
so it takes a while before i actually
start writing it
you know what i mean so i'll drink a
little whiskey
smoked cigar take a little take a little
time relax
and then i start writing it let's
imagine
a new screenwriter has their screenplay
bought or optioned
so everything's going great and then
they are fired off the project
is this a good thing yes it's an amazing
thing it's how my writing career started
because you're in the system now and
again it's a business
right so you knew you do something great
they give you a deal which is awesome
they give you money because that's what
comes with the deal
and that's awesome and then you're in
the mix of it and you're learning
how they operate by the notes that they
give you
and now other people in the industry
know that you're working for this studio
so they're going to want to meet with
you because you're working on this
project that was just announcing the
trades
now people know what's going on with you
like you're in the mix you're in the
game now
and then they get to a point where you
do
the writing and they look at it and they
go
this was my personal experience and i
sold
i would die for you to colombia they
were like wow
this is coming together like we can
start seeing this as a movie
so since we start seeing it as a movie
now let's get some real people in here
to get it done
so they fired us
it's business it's insurance
you know what i mean you're talking
about millions of dollars
you know what i mean most people won't
give their best friend two dollars
right so you're talking about millions
of dollars that are going to be spent
on these 100 and some pages
they need to make sure that that money
is going to turn into more money and
oftentimes with a new screenwriter
that means firing that screenwriter
bringing on a new one
that's already been in the mix maybe
they've written two or three films
that have been greenlit maybe the last
thing that they wrote was a big hit
maybe they wrote and directed a big
indie thing that blew up at sundance
it's an insurance policy for the studio
so the studio feels more comfortable to
go
forward with the piece it's not a bad
thing
it's never a bad thing it's a bad thing
if you look at it like a bad thing
but really it's you're in the mix now
you know what i mean you can take that
sale
and turn it into all kinds of stuff
especially
broken record if you have more material
[Music]
it's so important that's why i keep
saying it it's super important you got
to have more stuff
you know what i mean you just that's
just it's the nature of the beast
it's nature of the beast there are
millions and millions of dollars
to be made
you gotta have more stuff when you're
turning in that first draft
and you're giving it to whomever you're
working with
is it would you say you trust somebody
who's just more brutally honest with you
than somebody who wants to be nice and
keep the relationship going but maybe
they dance around things and they're not
i think you want listen you don't want
somebody that's just going to like
trash you right because that just kills
the confidence
but you also don't want somebody who's
gonna like pussyfoot around you
you know and not really give you the
real so i think it really does come down
to
developing relationships with people
through your writing i mean i haven't
always had the pleasure
to be able to just trust that i can
deliver that first draft
and we'll be able to rock out like i
haven't always had that
situation but i have it with these
people because
we're just so keyed into one another
like yeah we'll we'll have meetings and
they'll go
for like four or five hours and we have
a blast
you know we all share the same sense of
humor we all share the same
basic you know belief system we all have
the same
basic values we all see the world
essentially the same way
so it is a very unique situation for me
because i trust those guys i
can i can say like boom here it is this
is what i'm thinking what do you guys
think
and then they'll come at me and they'll
be like all right let's do this and this
and this and this and this and this
it's like you know listen it's
absolutely not normal
it's absolutely not the way it goes
but because i have this relationship
with them
if i'm wrong on the first draft all by
myself
i might be wrong on the second third
fourth right
all by myself but because i have this
team that i trust that knows what i want
my end result to be let's give him the
first draft
let's just get on with it if i'm wrong
i'm wrong and
you know we'll get to the point where
it's right and we get there a little
quicker
than me sitting around agonizing over uh
did i do this right am i wrong i don't
know
i have the luxury of not having
to do that it's nothing i would tell
anybody else to do it's nothing i would
recommend
for anybody else
i just happen to be very fortunate to
have looked into
the right folks for me
one of the running themes of this
interview today has been
a reference to your shirt record quote
unquote broken record
and that is have more content always
have more
so even when you go into pitch you have
more to show
what does that entail for you how much
is more
for you how many projects are we talking
about what do you have in your
quote arsenal
so full arsenal full arsenal
i did an interview interview
this is an interview i did an inventory
six months ago of everything i've
written
like everything and so
i sort of did this experiment where i
mapped out everything
and i thought okay if i if i if
every one of these things got made like
films
pilots not counting the length of how
long a television
show would run but you know pilot gets
shot
you know edited put on the air uh picked
up
film shot put in theaters or on stream
or whatever
like how long would it take if
everything and there were no hiccups
like you just got it
the money came in the buyers were there
the distribution was there just did it
like each piece without any hiccups how
long would it take to get everything
done
i would have to be 116 years old
for everything to get done
uh that i've written
this year there's been a lot more focus
on television
with the company that i'm working with
so there's only been one feature
one feature script that i wrote this
year
but there's been
five pilots
one of the pilots i've written the first
two seasons of the show
and the seasons are 10 episode seasons
uh another one of the pilots i've ridden
five episodes for
um this is tv this is yeah just the tv
so uh five tv pilots complete
two seasons
of completed scripts for one of the
pilots complete
five episodes of another of the tv
pilots
complete
so for the first one that's 20 scripts
because there are 10 episodes a season
oh okay so there's 20 episodes of
television
plus five more episodes of television
plus the three other pilots that i wrote
um i'm in the process of writing
one now
and i'm working on
two other feature scripts
that are incomplete
that's summer to summer
summer 18 summer 19.
so and then there's just a ton of other
ideas that have been like
jotted down that are for later
do you keep that in a file like do you
have like these idea
files oh here okay to my phone
and they have a notes thing on your
iphone so every time something pops up
in my head i pull up the notes
and then i sit there with it and
sometimes uh
sometimes it's just crappy so i delete
them
sometimes more stuff comes so i write
that stuff down
and then sometimes they turn into
full-on scripts
[Laughter]
um but yeah constant
constant constant constant constant
writing
how do you know if you were bored with a
story or do you just need more time with
it
i get bored stories all the time
so i stop
i i don't force anything
like this seems really cool okay this is
cool
oh this is kind of dead that's
that's not cool this is a yeah
yeah i start something else i don't get
rid of it
i just put it down and i start writing
something else
and inevitably
in writing something else an idea
will formulate that fixes this one
you know i'll like write something or
i'll be hanging out with someone or i'll
hear somebody say something i'm like
ah that would fix that other thing that
i stopped writing
so i go back that's all right now what
and then when that's done then go back
to the other thing
and then while i'm working on that
somebody will say something or i'll see
something in the news
oh that would make a good movie i'll
write that down
it's constant it's just constant
constant
creation literally i drive my wife
nuts constant creation and then
if it fizzles out i don't fret about it
i don't worry about it i don't struggle
with it i don't like oh how do i fit
i just put away because there's way more
other stuff to be doing and working on
you know do you think
the mark of a professional is to
continually finish
things
sure probably i mean you finish i i
finish
i finish more than i start but i am
constantly starting
it's not like i have like all these
unfinished
screenplays you know what i mean i i
tend to write
fast like if it comes to me it comes to
me
and so it goes when that flow starts to
like
peter out i don't try to force it i just
okay it's petered out we're done for
that and then i'm on to the next day
they always get finished but it's more
about
for me it's more about flow
it's not flowing it's no good because
the thing is you know
people will say like oh you should write
this many pages a day you should write
you know this
one or two scenes a day or whatever it
is but like you never know where your
head's gonna be you never know where
your creativity is gonna be you never
know what your energy's gonna be
so if i'm like not in the best space
and i'm just like pushing through the
right stuff to like meet this like
requirement i'm just going to write you
know
crappy pages i want to write crappy
pages
you know i want to have good pages so if
that means
that on tuesday i write
two pages that i on tuesday i write two
pages
if on thursday i write 15 pages
then on thursday i write 15 pages if on
friday
i just want to have a whiskey and write
no pages then i don't write no pages
but i don't beat myself up for anything
you know what i mean like
they're all there they're all constantly
all the characters are constantly like
just there living in my head
and so
at a certain point one of them will perk
up and be like hey
you know what would be cool if you did
this
oh yeah it is cool and i'll
do that and then sometimes i'll
scrape the whole thing and restart it
because i came up with something
cooler same story
same concept but like a way better angle
into it so if i've written the first act
and i got 30 pages in
something better came along i can make
those 30 pages even better but i got
rid of 30 pages i have they go i write
new
30 pages have you ever fallen in love
with a character
like like
falling in love with a character like
like i want to leave my wife for a year
like what are you like
you don't have no no you could you could
still
fall in love with something it doesn't
mean you have to change your life you
can just use
an idea of something an idea of someone
most of them
what's the point like if you don't if
you don't love it what's the point of
doing it
you know i mean if you're just writing
the thing to write the thing because you
think you're going to sell this thing
i guess there's value in that if you've
got a goal and you're set for that
but for me man i the stuff i sell
the stuff i want to sell i love the
stuff i want to make for myself
i love the characters in this thing i
love the characters in the movies i love
the characters in the tv
shows i love i mean i you know i come up
with this tv show i wrote two seasons of
it
i wrote two seasons 20 scripts
madly in love with it nobody asked me to
do that
i just want to stop
do you like current television um
[Music]
but you know current means
2019 not necessarily
america
i'm a huge like i'm never getting rid of
netflix
because netflix has a huge selection of
asian television
that's current that i love like
singaporean television
korean television thai
television taiwanese television chinese
television japanese television like
my entire netflix
interface has none of the stuff that
everybody's talking about
on netflix it's got all the asian stuff
like all of it they just really
to me
it's really strong emotional
stories and characters like across the
board
whether it's like comedies or romance
or action or the really cool stuff is
the historical stuff
there's a lot of really cool things that
are set
in you know ancient times
in korea which is like so cool because
like
it's kind of like an education about you
know what it was like
um so
most of my television watching
is watching asian television on netflix
most of it there is a new show
that i absolutely adore
that is on cinemax it's called jet
it stars carla gugino
i think it's created by sebastian
gutierrez i think that's his name i'm
not sure
anyway he wrote and directed
all the episodes and it's brilliant
and she's brilliant it's so cool it's
like a
quiet thriller she plays a
master thief um
she's trying to get out of the game but
then she's got this old boss that pulls
her back in
it's so good and she like the character
of jet
that carla gugino has created
so cool so cool so jet
it's probably my favorite show
now that anyone in america would know
about
um i saw dead to me on netflix
the christina applegate show i like that
um they call it a comedy i don't really
think it's a comedy but it was
very good uh
i'm kind of missing the boat on a lot of
the
broadcast network shows only because
i'm so obsessed with all the stuff on
netflix
so i don't really know if things are
good or bad to my liking or not
i'm just so stuck in asia
on netflix that
i just don't get to the to the american
stuff
i still haven't seen big little lies i
hear it's awesome
um i still haven't seen that
i can't even think of like what's on
the regular networks right now that's
like the hot stuff what's the hot stuff
on the
abc and the nbc and cbs i don't know
i hear there's a chicago thing happening
chicago fire
chicago pd chicago law chicago
sanitation
chicago is like it's like a bunch of
shows
and they're all the same show but
they're in chicago it's in different
departments
so i uh i i can't get into that stuff
but do you think comedy is the same as
it used to be
things things are funny comedy used to
be funny
like that used to be the definition of
comedy you know what i mean
like it used to be comedy
and you laugh and that's comedy
now it's more like
that's funny and that's comedy that's
not comedy
you know what i mean like comedy should
make you laugh
in my opinion and there's a lot of
things that i see
that are labeled as comedies and they're
not comedies
they're they're it's not that it's not
that they're invalid
you know it's just they're they're
they're statements
on social mores or
or culture or race or gender
and all of that's good and well and fine
but it's not a comedy it's not
comedy should make you laugh there's a
netflix
stand-up thing that everyone loves
i've not seen all of it um
i think it's called it's i think she's
an australian comedian
um it's
really good but it didn't make me laugh
you know it was like a ted talk really
you know there's like humorous moments
in it but it wasn't
i didn't find it to be funny and again
like it's not like it's not
valuable it's not like it's not timely
or relevant but
for me i want to laugh
at something called a
comedy well i mean like this is 40.
i watched it years later and i was like
oh i probably this is probably going to
be
like forced things no it was hilarious
was it really
the moment it started oh that's awesome
and i was like how could i have gone
this long without seeing it i totally
judged it
right and then i felt like an idiot for
judging it because it was so funny
right and the characters were so great
well see that might be exactly where i'm
at
i might be judging stuff prior to and
need to
pay a little bit more attention to
what's going on i mean
um it's always sunny in philadelphia
super hilarious every single episode i
love that show
that's just amazing oh my god so wrong
like everything is about it it's like
seinfeld on crack it's like everything
is wrong
they're awful people but it's funny and
it's saying something um
what else and this is more tv
i think i think i think there's more
leeway in film
that's true than there is in television
um
yeah i i can't really think of that
i you know who's really funny
but really funny like probably like the
best comedian out there in my opinion
right now
is ali wong ali wong has two
stand-up specials okay on netflix right
now and
um her film always be my maybe
she's hilarious off to check it out
dirty
dirty nasty but really really funny
were you a big sitcom kid back in the
day
i loved them loved them always thought
the sitcom would be like the perfect
place
to live as an actor did a lot of pilots
a lot of sitcom pilots didn't get picked
up
yeah sitcoms are fun man especially when
they're funny
cause they're not always funny no no
i mean like for to me taxi
amazing like you just couldn't best to
come ever
didn't even have to speak hands down you
know best to come in the world
jim ignatowski would just come in i know
and and
just that was it just a look is
the perfect storm of character and story
and
have a friend we always have this
argument of taxi versus cheers
oh that's a good one and i always tell
them
you got no cheers without taxi
similar they're coming into sort of a
working-class environment there's a cast
of characters they're sort of the alpha
same makers okay tax came first
tax was a hit abc cancels taxi
nbc picks it up for its final season
cheers ends up on nbc
no chairs without taxi
so for me taxi is the king
even though cheers ran for like 16 000
years after
taxi
so good was so good so so so good
yeah i love that show i wish i could i
wish that was on the air somewhere
that'd be
that'd be great i know everybody's
watching friends over
and over and over again um in the office
office was great but no no that's that's
not the same kind of sitcom you know
it's more of a single camera thing
whereas like
i feel like they're different beasts
there's like the single camera comedy
like the office i think that's a
different species of comedy than like
friends or taxi like you know
that three camera audience
thing i know a lot of people don't like
the audience laughing
because they feel like oh i'm being told
to laugh at this whatever and i get that
i don't know i think i think there's a
little nostalgia
that's kind of cool about sitcom
sitcom laughter sitcom comedy
snark to it for a new screenwriter who's
just finished
their first screenplay what do they do
with it i don't know
okay
um all right so you're saying like you
write a screenplay you don't know
nothing about nothing right you just
wrote something
okay um
internet internet
this is this is the the connectivity
of the world is in everybody's
palm because it's on the phone there are
contests and websites there's all kinds
of stuff
where you can submit a screenplay
and get some kind of feedback on it
like if you're waiting for universal to
show up
and grab up your scripts you'll be
waiting a very long time
however get it out there
find it let people say no to you
like don't be so precious about it
just get it out there because if you do
that
and you put it in the hands of different
places
and different websites like inktip.com
like where you can just like
post your script there for producers to
look at
if they dig your log line
you're gonna learn stuff and you're
gonna understand like what's working
if nobody clicks on your script you've
got work to do
if people do click on your script you're
going to find out what the deal is from
them
you know especially now it's
weird because the whole writer's guild
thing that's going on
so i mean i guess you could submit to
agents
i don't know if agent can touch anything
now i don't know what it is
but um
even before that the that whole process
is
harder because agents are agencies
are also companies now
they have bottom line they gotta have a
certain amount of money coming in
and they're dependent on higher level
clients
that are known on the studio level
doesn't mean you can't get an
agent but a lot of times
these contests film festivals have
screenwriting contests in them
you know the sundance lab is a place
that you can submit your script to
a lot of agents are judges at that thing
so you send your script something an
agent might see it and be like
cool now you've skipped a bunch of steps
which is a lot better than you know
complaining on twitter about nobody
reading your script
you know it's it's work you got to get
out and
do a little work you know nothing's just
going to land in your lap
nobody is going to land in your lap
everybody's out there trying to get
their stuff done too
you know doesn't mean you can't work
together with people but
show them you're willing to do something
get it out there
move it around what about what you said
earlier is like let people say no to you
yeah is that like a skill yeah
you kidding everybody hates no now i'm
you know back in the day no was
normal yeah they know has changed
do you think no has a different meaning
nowadays
no
sorry made me laugh um
no i mean it's no
no no this is noah's no is no
i think the difference is
i think back in the day
no wasn't the end
of anything it still isn't the end of
anything
but i think people perceive it now as
the end of
anything because everything's been made
so
easily accessible you know what i mean
like nobody wants to wait for anything
like no one has any patience so if
they hear no well that sucks that's over
all right whatever
but it's not there's
there's a reason behind no that you can
benefit from
all you gotta do is ask because people
are very happy to tell you why they said
no
you know what i mean nobody is like why
did you say no
hmm no they'd
be very happy to tell you exactly why
they said no to you
and there's knowledge in there there's
value in it
and if you've never written anything
before people are going to tell you no
if you've written stuff before
people are going to tell you no if you
sold things people are going to tell you
no
if you've won awards people are going to
tell you no
again different brands you know
different brands different companies
different personalities different
tastes all of that so if you're just
getting cooking let it cook a little bit
might say yes then how far along are you
you put your first script out and you
send it to the sundance lab or you throw
it on
inktip and somebody goes this is great
we want it now
cool it's great they say yes
but you know no doesn't
prevent yes no doesn't mean
there are no yeses coming you know what
i mean
no doesn't mean anything
beyond not right now
really i had a
friend who had a friend
who's an executive at a cable network
and he was constantly pitching her stuff
and they were very good friends
and she was like no no
no doesn't doesn't fit doesn't fit
doesn't fit then he got together with a
different writing partner
and they came up with something together
and he pitched that thing to her
and she went oh i like that you guys
should come in
but he got told no like eight times
like eight different things you know so
no no builds relationships no
brings you fans no gets your name out
there
so yeah no really isn't any different
than it used to be
it's just people i think don't
understand
the positive behind it the way
maybe they used to back in the day
why do people fail in hollywood
do people fail um
uh because they're people because
everybody fails
is that yeah like everybody
like everybody fails all
over the world in every profession
and industry ever everybody fails
unless you mean like
why do people fail like why do people
not
end up with a career that they want
or just failure failure career that they
want
uh any variety of reasons um
timing sometimes
you're ahead of your time sometimes
you're behind your time
uh
type sometimes
what the industry is looking for you
don't
fit like
the hypothetical scenario
right now we are seeing a massive push
for more inclusion of
transgender people people of different
races creeds colors you know gender
all of that that did not exist
5 10 15 20 years ago so
let's say you were one of those people
that had been on the outskirts
of what we now realize was just
nonsense to keep excluding people
and you were like bucking the system
because
you wanted it and you kept getting
[Music]
doors slammed in your face and now
you're at an age where maybe they're not
now looking for that age
so the time didn't line up for you
you know which
is wrong but i still don't believe that
that means you still can't have the
career that you want i
firmly believe that
where your head's at determines
where you end up and it's hard
sometimes to keep your head on straight
it's hard to
kind of go through everything and still
say
that's okay that's okay that's okay
um
but if he can do it
morgan freeman got his very first
meaningful
you know career role when he was 50.
so the morgan freeman career we're all
aware of
didn't happen until after 50.
you know what i mean
i don't know what happened i don't know
morgan freeman
but possibilities
exist i think you got to believe in
yours
maybe it's harder
to keep believing after a certain amount
of
rejection or hurt or time
and you know that's for every person to
decide on their own
but if you can push through it
i think what you want
you can get